stay down fine don't worry I could do
this all day hello friends I'm Lucy from
GameSpot joined here by Tamora sane not
tomorrow
I've been see Captain America Civil War
very excited to talk about it I know
you've got some questions for me the
lovely people are home have some
questions what makes I put out a Twitter
shout-out so these are going to be some
spoiler free impressions and answers to
your questions talk a bit about how the
movie works some of the characters let's
get started let's get started so best
point to start with is obviously gonna
be what did you think
did you like here what's it good does it
suck like Batman no that's mean Batman
had redeeming qualities but no I really
really enjoyed Civil War so it's kind of
like this classic Marvel Cinematic
Universe fun party that we all know and
love there's a lot of action a lot of
jokes they do a really great job at
managing the ensemble cast because there
are a lot of heroes and there's a lot of
stuff going on at any one time the plot
remains surprisingly really cohesive I
think it can be enjoyed on its own but
I've seen all the Marvel movies read the
comics a lot of the comics as well I've
read Civil War so going in I felt like I
had a better understanding because as I
said there are there's a lot going on
some of the more emotional moments might
get lost on you if you're not really
aware and speaking of like emotional
moments do they take that kind of
picking of two well-known heroes against
each other and deliver on it is it done
in a good way going in I was team cap
but I mean the basic premise of Civil
War is that the Avengers are finally
starting to be held accountable for
their admittedly accidental when they've
destroyed New York or you know lifted
the city of sokovia and dropped it on
the earth killing hundreds if not
thousands of people so the world is sort
of saying to them you know we need to
start holding you accountable we're very
grateful please sign these Accords to
kind of say that you're working with us
and we can hold you responsible and
basically put a leash on you a little
bit
so Ironman is very much for signing
these ëcause whereas teamcap is very
much again I thought they did actually
quite a good job I mean Iron Man's
reasoning for signing I'm not gonna
spoil kind of the event but they are
really solid and quite emotional and you
feel quite invested in why he wants to
sign
whereas I thought team cap was a bit
less convincing is that actually
explored because we've seen we
understand what hind man's kind of point
is they want to put a leash on these
essentially powers that can destroy the
wall but we kind of haven't seen too
much of what Captain America's after you
can see that it's something to do with
Bucky and there's a friendship thing
going on there is that explored further
as it just kind of like this is the
scenario and now watch these two teams
fight with Iron Man we've seen in
previous movies so he has a conscience
so when he understands that his the
stark weapons are being used you know
for ill means he immediately stops
production so you know that he has a
conscience in that way whereas Captain
America is a military man and that he
use a military figurehead so for him to
kind of reject Authority and reject
orders in that way is quite strange and
it's not really as convincing so we
asked our Twitter followers for some
questions which we've accidentally
already yea answered all of them there
is one main one left and that is from
red Scorpio underscore 8786 other red
Scorpios weren't interested in this
video at all he says are there any mid
or post credits scenes mm-hmm it's a
Marvel movie of course there are there
are too so there's a mid and sadly in
the screening I was at they didn't have
the post so I know what the mid is no
idea on the post so don't be one of
those people who leaves a Marvel movie
before you've seen the post reddit no
spoilers but are they good all right yes
it's another like it's a setup okay
excellent and obviously there is one
more character do we want to start
discussing him now all right if you
didn't see the end of I think it was the
second civil war trailer and you don't
want this character reveal I mean it's
kind of difficult to avoid it if you
have somehow not been on
Internet and you haven't been seen all
the hot means hot memes burst by it man
yeah so he's great he's been spider-man
for about six months but he's still
really young and naive and immature and
he's dressed trying to find his place at
the Avengers and he's seriously he's a
lot of fun and the things he says you
know he sort of is he's another theme
stealer and it's a great thing we've had
many many years of bad spider-man he's a
great man does it feel like he's a
different spider-man do you feel more
confident in this guy yeah because he's
he's the young kid who's actually a
young kid I mean like Andrew Garfield
Tobey Maguire were like well into their
late twenties when they were probably
playing spider-man and they definitely
didn't have that young nervous energy
and I think that's that's what's great
about Tom Hollands spider-man is that he
is just excited to be there and he's
just sort of and I imagine like on set
that's probably what he felt because
he's coming into this
multibillion-dollar franchise and he's
just excited to be there and it really
translates it wasn't it was a vine of
him doing backflips on a trampoline a
little while back and I kind of gave me
some confidence in him because he was
like I did a backflip I was like yeah
I've just done a back flip everyone all
right so there you have it Lucy has seen
Captain America Civil War and gives it
two thumbs up I'm excited about it more
so than any other superhero movie coming
out this year and you can read the
written review for Captain America Civil
War on GameSpot calm and we'll see you
next time
you
you